皆さんはカロリーゼロの食べ物での実物を見たことはありますでしょうか
結構流行ってましてなんか軽いゼロの食べ物とかなんかなに0
0000高良も0ゼリーも0
2激戦が起きたのかと思ったいろんなものが0にないっツアーでこの世界このままでは
すべての補助がムーンに帰ってしまうということを言いたいわけじゃないんですけど
0どういうことだと私は思っていまして食べてもないんですよ何も食べてもゼロやませ
んですか兄弟ってここにたくさんの n 0キロカロリーの中デザートを準備しました
寒天というのかなんかぜ
いいなんですけどこれもかなり0これも0これも0これも0
[音楽]
ないやんないんですよあのこれ皆さんが画面ゾーン京都神戸があるように見えるんです
けどこれ全部じゃないんですよ
護衛がてしまう本当になって臓器の管理ということはくっても意味がないということに
なります
何かに似たような子だというといったんですけどねくっだが体重が変わるのかってたん
ですね香りをあたり見てやっぱり水飲んだらどんなもテンション増えるんで体重が
変わるのは間違い
ないと思うんですけどくってもかなりになんないから大丈夫得るものの a に
食べれるはずなんですよ
管理がないから食っても食っても5的なも食べるんですけど僕自身食ったことになって
ないんで
やつ万人が言いたいかよくわかんなくなってきたといいですねとりあえずここにあるの
全部食べます強いで今回の検証は0キロかっぴーの食べ物なら
a 2クール雪
k 紹介 j いやもう何が何でも全部くれますからね
いただきます
これで0kcal って一体どうなってんだろうね
えっ
あ
まぁまぁ美味しいですとっぴするほどでもないんですけどそれだけでも美味しいです
これなら向けにくれるいやマジで本気にくれるナム下に食えるんですけどまぁ= d 方
はラクスルとあんまり美味しくないですうん
6で済むただ
必ずくれますどうぞよそ
[音楽]
うんん全然言え
全然余裕まだまだ行きますどんどん行きましょう
2個目ぐらいでコーヒー味ってなんかやばいぬ
[音楽]
うん馬待ってなぜならコーヒーゼリー美味しいぞこれ
うーん
ものはございません
th
me
car
まだいけますさんこれ取れましたおかしいなぁゼロのはず何年か
[音楽]
苦しいです何なんだろうなこれいただきますオレンジは美味しそうねえっ
ん
[音楽]
わーいや絶対食いますけどね
大谷何が何だろうぞどんな手を使ってでもわかるこそ方に違いまあ
前理由は2つんだけど頬
いきます混ぜます
うーん
不思議ですねぇ
全然食べた気になりません灘もなくついてますねも米きます
[音楽]
ワカメっても俺がおかしいのかもしれないですけど部壕きついです
だじゃあ
ああああああ
立っ
あんこから探査ください
夏0サティ追加あれが悪いぱこれは ps 4泊ほぼ僕がおかしいんですたボケ
ちょっと体調不良で70
色がラリーを食べれないのでちょっと夏とこ協力して食べますはい
ゼロなんでねや情けねえなあ
[音楽]
何もなんないでしょ
やばいも多くて全部結構やばいよかや
6本ため追われましたん
誰だ
じゃあおかしいよ僕はをバネにね様なんでだろう
このまだゼロですね今
8位
早送り辞典20秒後の竜を見てほしいです
[音楽]
0じゃねーですああ
はっはっはちょっとおかしいん0-0ん
[音楽]
たまたまこの2人がおかしいだけな気がしますやと夢想家たちがオーバーすると分
一般的な人であれば全然苦悩を抱えると思うんですけど
秩序我々がちょっと調整が悪いみたいなぜか食べれませんですもう無理
4日
違うんでは不思議な感覚に襲われていれば勝って実感がないんだけど気持ちをあげたい
な
見てにゃば月やばいえっいや俺止めてるの危機を体で秋を感じる今
んそれ
あああああっ
んだっはぁはぁっ
いや風を無理だ
危ないん
[音楽]
うんっ
なんだよ吐き税
あ
ああああああああ
ではで土木がもう本当の本当に食べれないと感じました
ゼロカロリーゼリー無限にクール雪が雑感ぶりかなと感じました
一応記録を食べたんですけどこれ以上空と多分本当にヤバイんで
0kcal といえども間に空ことは不可能であることが今回実証されていました
坂内僕たちがおかしい
だけがもしれないね
多分そうでしょうね端末幻想ですね0kcal なんて食べたことにならない
上に来るのかもしれません
[音楽]
いやだいやだうんはぁっ
me
うううう
re あった
それに登ってしまったものはあの責任を持って食べさせていただきます
みんなでね